this is from the college fix white
guests are banned from the common spaces
at the person of color house an
off-campus housing option for berkeley
students according to a photo of the
guest rules recently posted on reddit
under a section labeled guess in common
spaces it states guests are allowed in
common spaces but please be mindful if
there are house members in the room
beforehand white guests are not allowed
in common spaces
the poc house
states in part that many members moved
in to be able to avoid white violence
and presence
when students do bring a guest the rules
direct them to announce it in the house
guest chat and note if they are white
white guy coming through white we got a
white if there was a university they
also set up a white house and they
called it that the house for the white
people will be burned to the ground it
is unthinkable that any institution
would ever set up anything specifically
for white people yet they do this for
quote poc it's wildly illegal